Mr President could you give an update on
that leak investigation the leaked
documents I can't right now there's a
full-blown investigation going on as you
know with the intelligent recruiting and
Justice Department
and they're getting close we don't I
don't have an answer how concerned are
you about The Fleets
are you concerned about sometimes it's
time to go let's go oh we gotta move I'm
not concerned about the lady because I'm
concerned if it happened
but there's nothing contemporaneous that
I'm aware of that is of good
consequences are you concerned about
relationships
[Applause]
25 years old from The Good Friday
agreement what are your hopes for the
next 25 years for the people of Ireland
both jurisdictions it gets even closer
that the uh I hope that the government
began to function as it used to in terms
of functioning as a representative body
in the north I think that's necessary
and the best for you I'll decide not for
me to decide but I think that I'm very
uh I'm very proud of my colleague George
Mitchell I think he did a fine job he
said 300 days of failure and one day
success and we got to build on that one
day continuing thank you Mr President
it's all British Secrets safe in
American hands Mr President